another issue with this viral
dermatologist video about lotions being
bad he also says that humectants dry out
skin below 70 humidity because they pull
water from the deeper dermis and you dry
out skin in the long run unless you use
an occlusive on top there actually isn't
any good evidence that this happens it
shows up as a fact in a lot of papers
and textbooks but if you follow the
references it goes nowhere this is also
why so many people say physical
sunscreens reflect and scatter uv it's
just a myth that people kept repeating
in their publications without checking
but we do have studies that show
humectants can actually hydrate skin
without occlusives on top and yet these
ingredients are most likely drawing
water up from the deeper layers of your
skin but the deeper layers are very
large and very wet the dermis is 10 to
40 times thicker than the epidermis and
it's 60 water if a couple percent of
that goes into your epidermis it's no
big deal and the dermis keeps getting
chopped up with water from the rest of
your body as well which is 70 water